Good morning
Believe nation! its Evan my one word is "believe"
I believe in you and I want to see that awesome thing that you have inside you
Explode out into the universe to have a major impact!!
So to help you on your journey today's message is "believe" over the you Gary Vaynerchuk!
Sometimes a lot of people may try a new initiative, and then they don't get an immediate reaction
And they think it's a failure, (Gary)"That's right" okay, I wanna go back to your YouTube videos with the Wine Library
You know you had so much content out there. How did you stick in there? How did you keep yourself motivated?
Because I believe in my strategies, and I'm patient (as sh$$ bleeped out) like
All great stuff especially when you're innovating doesn't happen right away
This notion that like "Oh Gary I tried it. I spent five hundred bucks on Facebook Ads it doesn't work"
Well what if your videos sucked what if your product and service sucks?
I
Tend to do things that are very early. that has been my career. you I when I do things I believe in them
I stick with them based on intuition even though for 18 months nobody watched my wine videos at all
I knew it was right. I was right. There's been things. I've done that I've jumped off of very quickly
I started to Gary v app V-E-E chat like WeChat
That was funny for my fans .great CRM one on one.
Didn't feel right after a week or two spend plenty money building it knew it stopped it after you know a couple months
Wine Library TV five years every day YouTube
Decided to change at to "Daily Grape" insular app you could buy stuff subscription for reviews
It was a lot of fun only did it for five months stopped it because I didn't feel right anymore.
It's always hard to know when to jump off something new.
But I find that people don't believe in what they're doing. they hear "A guru"
and they do it begrudgingly cuz their boss wants them to or they're like "well Gary's right a lot
So let me do it"
But they don't believe it .and so then they jump they're looking for "no's" instead of "yes's". everything I do
Every business development every event I do every time I try new marketing tactics or sales tactic I'm looking for the yes
(Interviewer) "Right" (Gary) I'm looking for the yes, and if the no punches me will then I'm like "crap then no punched me"
I believe the majority of people when they try new tactics are looking for the"no"  (interviewer) "mm-hmm"
(Gary)And you're gonna getting a lot of subtle "no's" immediately (interviewer)"right" (Gary) and so I think that's why that happens.
Gary speaking to a crowd "What's the most important word, EVER?!"
Tony Robbins "Let me give you the one word secret to happiness, ONE WORD, this all you need to be happy!" (interviewer to Will.I.Am.) If you have to think of one word
That's most important to you or that sums you up or that would be like a little beacon..
Evan:Hey Believe Nation if you want to know what the most important one word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey Will.I.Am and Howard Schultz I have a very special secret video for you! check the description for details